[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Perú desde hace más de 20 años
las víctimas del programa anticoncepción
quirúrgica voluntaria luchan por
justicia el programa dejó a miles de
afectados y la mayoría eran indígenas
quechuas y familias de escasos recursos
económicos se ha descrito como un crimen
contra la humanidad una limpieza étnica
e incluso como un genocidio la mayoría
son mujeres pobres de zonas indígenas de
Perú que afirman que fueron acosadas
chantajeadas y atacadas por la fuerza
para ser esterilizadas en el marco del
programa plan Nacional de población la
idea era fomentar el control de la
natalidad para tratar de reducir la
pobreza y promover el crecimiento
económico escuchemos al expresidente
Alberto fujimori cuando la campaña se
puso en marcha
extraña que dentro de alguna semana
vamos a iniciar una campaña pero
agresiva a fondo como dije
para difundir todo estos métodos de la
planificación familiar y para que
efectivamente con este control en la
tasa en la natalidad puede El Perú
entonces
tener mejores condiciones de vida
entre el año 1990 y 2000 se
esterilizaron alrededor de 270.000
mujeres y también 22.000 hombres muchos
de ellos solo hablaban quechua con poco
o nada de español y dicen que no podían
entender a los funcionarios ni los
documentos del gobierno otros
simplemente dicen que los responsables
los obligaron a esterilizarse un juez
peruano abrió una investigación en
diciembre de 2021 contra el expresidente
fujimori tres de sus ministros de salud
y otros funcionarios de la época ellos
sostienen que todas las esterilizaciones
fueron consensuadas pero miles de
víctimas afirman lo contrario Esta es la
historia
es una reunión de mujeres que han sido
heridas pero que se han negado a
Rendirse todas ellas son campesinas
pobres y Todas dicen que fueron
esterilizadas contra su voluntad en los
años 90
porque no estamos ya acostumbrados a
reunirnos porque por nuestra lucha más
de 25 años ya estamos en este lucha y
Seguiremos luchando y por verdad
justicia y reparación
ruta Zúñiga es presidenta de ampaez
la asociación de mujeres peruanas
afectadas por esterilizaciones forzadas
se reúnen periódicamente para
intercambiar información y hacer balance
de la investigación en curso en cada
reunión las víctimas hablan en quechua
su lengua materna
sobre secuelas físicas y psicológicas
si hay mucha tristeza Sí porque las
compañeras cuentan que no que tienen
dolores en todos sus cuerpos que se
ponen a llorar en qué momento ha sido
que me han ligado en ese momento porque
a veces los dolores son fuertes las
compañeras esos se están quejándose la
mayoría de estas mujeres han sufrido
dolores abdominales desde su operación
me pasas ahí se realizan las pruebas
médicas pero hasta ahora ningún médico
ningún tratamiento Parece ser eficaz
resultados del hospital de las clínicas
de lo que estoy mal de mi ligadura señor
periodista y todo estos y cada vez que
voy tengo que gastar
y Ni aún así no estoy bien papi siempre
me encuentro mal
y todo traumada parece una borracha así
no me recuerdo lo que hago lo que hablo
no me recuerdo una lucha ha sido mi vida
no hay ni sueño
a través de ampaez estas mujeres luchan
por la justicia en diciembre de 2021 se
anunció la apertura de una investigación
judicial tras 16 años de investigación
preliminar
[Música]
un motivo de Esperanza para todas las
víctimas
137 denunciantes están registradas para
testificar ruta vive en la comunidad de
pampaconga en el departamento de cusco
en el corazón de los Andes peruanos
[Música]
desde su casa gestiona un Modesto
restaurante para viajeros de paso esta
actividad le permite mantener a su
familia
ruta nunca olvidará el día en que se
llevó a cabo la esterilización Como
tantas otras mujeres dice que los
médicos no le explicaron nada intentó
ponerse a la cirugía cuando se negó
llegó una ambulancia para llevar la casa
escondida en su habitación con un recién
nacido en brazos rute fue trasladada por
la fuerza al hospital tengo un pedido
que me hace un rato me llamó para que
relieve 50 tamales para este preparando
preparando llevo a vender así los días
domingos también si ese es mi trabajo
porque con eso sí que era por la
universidad Me solvento algo para pagar
de la luz de otras cosas porque si no
hago nada sin para mí ya no hay ni
trabajo nada de dónde voy a sacar qué
voy a hacer ruta dice que se despertó en
medio de docenas de otras mujeres
algunas de ellas tendidas en el suelo la
enviaron a casa sin explicaciones hoy es
imposible trabajar en el campo como
antaño solo su marido únicamente puede
cultivar una pequeña parte de sus
tierras
[Aplausos]
te vamos a hacer un cortecito pequeñito
nomás pero ya este ya no vas a volver a
tener más hijos ya porque ya tienes
cuatro hijos y a dónde más ya ustedes en
el campo parece como sus hijos que hasta
que no pueden tenerlo criarlo lo tienen
de ahí este empieza a cortarme estoy
sintiendo el dolor ya cuando más
profundo me está cortando estoy
sintiendo más dolor y le digo pues
doctor por favor me duele me duele le
decía agárrale a esta mujer agárrale
agárrale así entonces me agarraron uno
me ha aplastado de mi cabeza y mi mano
me ha amarrado mi pie me ha amarrado y
ahí reciente me terminaron de cortarme
ahí recién es lo que me han colocado la
vía que tenía
Pablo
Buenos días
[Música]
antes trabajábamos todo toda esta
chacras todo esto
también esto igual
el agua hay que ir arriba soltado unos
dos tres kilómetros arriba a soltar agua
para todo esto ahora Yo solía no puedo
Ya solo me encuentro y y rute ya no
puede entrar no puede porque
se encarga en la casa nomás a hacer unas
cuantas cositas porque le duelen la
cintura le duele la barriga así todos
los nervios le duele y hace él ya debe
estar ya en cosas más fáciles que hacer
en la casa
en todo Perú se esterilizó a unas
300.000 mujeres entre 1996 y 2000 en el
marco de una campaña de lucha contra la
pobreza
según el expresidente Alberto fujimori
las operaciones eran voluntarias
pero hoy 8000 mujeres están inscritas en
el registro de víctimas de
esterilización forzada Paulina es una de
ellas
[Música]
cuando le dejé esta parte me duele hasta
le deje Entonces no te hemos hecho la
así me dijeron que no sabía mi esposo ni
yo tampoco para Paulina como para tantos
otros las consecuencias económicas son a
veces dramáticas ahorita están sufriendo
pueden ir de tanto y ahí gastas los
doctores
comida también estoy así yo nomás mandé
otro mi hijo está en hospital Ahorita va
a llegar está mal tiempo ya y no puedo
decirlo como tienen familia ellos no me
pueden mantener yo tengo que hacerme
refuerzo señor periodista por mis hijos
[Música]
al día siguiente volvemos a encontrarnos
con rute
no muy lejos de su casa quiere
presentarnos a santuza otra víctima
esterilizada antes de tener hijos solo
tenía 14 años nunca se casó
holancita
nada nada me he preguntado estoy enojada
estoy triste así cuando no tengo hijos
y tu señora bonita
pero cuando no tengo hijos estoy triste
a su lado rute apoya a santuza cómo hace
con tantas otras mujeres destrozadas
bueno Yo te diría hermana Santos ponte
fuerte somos una mujer bien luchadora
somos machas hay que pararnos bien Y
claro Hay que luchar en nuestra lucha
hasta las últimas consecuencias
conseguir siempre nos hacemos respetar
Claro porque tú no estás solita Ni yo
tampoco estamos solitas la organización
es a nivel nacional y todo el mundo a
nivel nacional Sabe qué es lo que nos ha
pasado y por verdad y Justicia y
reparación claro justicia preparación
necesitamos entonces
chao compañera
[Música]
Lima capital de Perú Aquí también se
desarrolla la lucha de las víctimas de
esterilizaciones forzadas minutos antes
de una reunión en el Ministerio de
Justicia y Derechos Humanos
expresa su impaciencia en 25 años de
lucha el gobierno nunca ha indemnizado a
estas mujeres
en un intento de acelerar el proceso
ruta viajó desde pampacunga
nosotros ya estamos cansados que en
palabras nos dicen nos hacen pasear que
hoy día tiene que haber un solución y es
por eso estoy así sobre que estoy un
poco mal de salud que tengo que tiene
que decirnos la reparación integral
individual que hoy tiene que ser la
solución que nos dé
ampaez cuenta con la ayuda de un asesor
en sus conversaciones con el gobierno
una voluntaria Acompaña a las víctimas
desde 1996 han sido varios años de
engaños de promesas y
por primera vez tuvimos un borrador de
de Propuesta pero que es bastante
limitada entonces hoy día venimos a ver
si han habido avances a una
contrapropuesta que ha avanzado la
organización con todas sus bases
y a eso venimos a conversar
el Ministerio de Justicia no permitió
que nuestras cámaras filmaran esta
reunión ni respondió a nuestras
peticiones de entrevistas durante varios
años
ha mantenido reuniones con diversos
organismos gubernamentales peruanos pero
las conversaciones se han estancado en
este martes de septiembre de nuevo
reciben un baldado de agua fría el
Ministerio pide más tiempo para estudiar
la solicitudes de reparación de las
víctimas
[Música]
nosotros nunca nos hemos negado a los
diálogos pero nos parece excesivo Cuanto
más diálogos van a ver No eso se ha
expresado hoy día de que cada diálogo
cada
conversación con nuevas autoridades o
las que ya existen ya resultan
humillantes y están afectando a la
dignidad de las víctimas no 25 años
después de los hechos los responsables
de la campaña de esterilización nunca
han sido condenados
archivado en varias ocasiones el caso de
las víctimas se encuentra hoy finalmente
ante la justicia penal pero el proceso
sigue plagado de dificultades hasta
ahora los presuntos autores no han
comparecido en las vistas
esa tenaz lucha de las víctimas Ha
logrado que hoy día estemos en una
circunstancia de que el caso está
judicializado no en este trayecto no han
transcurrido varios gobiernos pero
también ocurrió que se han archivado
hasta en cinco oportunidades archivaron
el caso el partido político al que
pertenecía en este grupo de personas han
tenido el poder en el congreso no no
podemos descartar que se haya utilizado
no algunos mecanismos para poder
entorpecer o poder este
dilatar más este caso no pero lo
importante ahorita es que el caso
avanzado
cuando nuestro equipo se puso en
contacto con ellos dos de los
principales acusados no quisieron
responder a nuestras preguntas las
esterilizaciones forzadas siguen siendo
un tema reservado en los medios de
comunicación peruanos no es de extrañar
según la socióloga rosa mezza que cree
que las mujeres indígenas Siempre han
estado desatendidas en Perú
Este es el grupo social que siempre está
olvidado el grupo social al que siempre
se considera que que vale menos que no
que no
cómo decirlo es el grupo social que
históricamente ha sido olvidado es
sexismo es machismo es racismo y también
es clasismo Entonces
es triste pero por un lado no tan
sorprendente que algo que afecte
específicamente a mujeres indígenas haya
sido dejado de lado como si fuera menos
importante
Más allá de la batalla legal las
víctimas también piden ser escuchadas y
comprendidas por las autoridades
peruanas
que el gobierno actual que nos pida
perdón porque ya tantos años que no que
estamos en esta lucha que ningunos no
hemos conseguido ni nos hemos podido
sentarnos y ahora es el momento que te
que tiene que pedirnos Perdón Siquiera
por lo menos darnos una solidaridad a
estas mujeres campesinas que somos
quechua hablantes para poder para que
nos pueda darles esa fuerza Siquiera por
lo menos que nos dé ese aliento que En
qué situación estamos
Contra viento y marea las víctimas de
esterilizaciones forzadas continúan su
lucha en Perú con la esperanza de que
algún día reciban algún alivio antes de
que sea demasiado tarde
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Perú conocimos
las historias de las mujeres que piden
justicia por las esterilizaciones
forzadas que se han conocido por más de
dos décadas en el país una práctica que
es considerada un crimen contra la
humanidad bajo la ley internacional
recuerde que puede Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores Hasta pronto